si on nous décrypterons comme chaque
soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 9 novembre
[Musique]
une semaine après l'entrée en vigueur du
confinement le protocole sanitaire
renforcée dans les lycées les
établissements sont invités à diminuer
le premier tweet et via un accueil en
2000 groupe ares niveau et en recourant
au travail à distance
ce protocole jugé insuffisant par
plusieurs syndicats qui appellent à la
grève demain
côté nouvelles encourageantes un vaccin
contre le rotavirus serait efficace à
90% annonce aujourd'hui des laboratoire
américain pfizer et bi en teck
[Musique]
donald trump ne reconnaît pas sa défaite
il prévoit d'organiser une série de
rassemblements pour contester les
résultats de la présidentielle
américaine john brennan lui a déjà
ouvert la voie de la transition en
formant ses équipes avec deux priorités
affichées la réconciliation d'une
amérique divisée et la lutte contre la
pandémie celui que les médias américains
ont donné vainqueur de l'élection
présidentielle a ouvert une cellule de
crise sur les pipes des mythes coville
19 le pays compte plus de 230 mille
décès liés à la pandémie
un mini sommet sur une réponse
européenne face au terrorisme france
autriche allemagne y seront en
visioconférence ce mardi juste après une
rencontre à paris entre emmanuel macron
et le chancelier autrichien sebastian
course des discussions qui interviennent
une semaine après l'attentât janice de
vienne et après évidemment celui de nice
le renforcement du protocole sanitaire
annoncé jeudi dernier par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale est entrée en
vigueur aujourd'hui
pour en parler nous retrouvons tout de
suite en direct notre reporter mona moon
et l'or devant le ministère bonsoir mona
ce protocole sanitaire est donc entré en
vigueur aujourd'hui de quoi s'agit-il
concrètement vous l'avez dit stéphanie
face à la grogne des enseignants un
renforcement du protocole sanitaire a
été annoncée jeudi dernier par le
ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer une annonce censée répondre aux
inquiétudes des enseignants qui
dénonçait et des classes surchargées en
pleine crise sanitaire il est entré en
vigueur aujourd'hui un protocole qui
prévoit la division est des classes en
2000 groupe l'apprentissage à distance
et à 50% en présentiel et un contrôle
continu pour les examens du baccalauréat
le tout pour éviter au maximum qu'il y
ait des classes ou des cantines bondé
est d'élèves mais ces mesures elles sont
considérées comme étant suffisante et
surtout selon les syndicats elle
n'aurait rien de nouveau on l'a vu aussi
ces derniers jours plusieurs lycéens
dans plein de lycées en france ont
exprimé leur colère ont essayé de
bloquer tant bien que mal
l'entrée des lycées encore aujourd'hui à
compiègne et il ya eu des échauffourées
entre forces de l'ordre et lycéens et
qui dénonçait à protocole
iberville adaptée à la situation alors
justement un mona un appel à la grève a
été lancé par certains syndicats
d'enseignants pour demain mardi
oui justement cette situation tendue
elle a poussé plusieurs syndicats
d'enseignants a appelé à la grève
nationale dans tout le pays ils
demandent plus de moyens plus de
matériel et surtout plus de recrutement
chez les enseignants et surtout aussi
plus en plus d'agents pour nettoyer les
salles cette grève elle pourrait être
reconduite ce 17 novembre prochain merci
mona el au hameau dès lors en direct du
ministère de l'éducation alors cette
question l'école est-elle un nid à kovy
de l'école at-elle les moyens de
prémunir enseignants et élèves du virus
ou bien faut-il à tout prix conserver
les écoles ouvertes ne serait ce que
pour l'éducation des enfants place à
notre décryptage avec nos invités pour
en parler avec nous en direct
hubert salle à un porte-parole de la pp
fédération des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement public nicolas ghesquière
professeur de français et mister du
mouvement les stylos rouges avec nous
également en direct alexis poulain un
autre éditorialiste bonsoir à tous les
trois messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors si votre
mouvement nicolas glières les stylos
rouges avec plusieurs syndicats qui
appelaient à la grève demain vous dit en
substance nous sommes livrés aux
qu'ovide enseignants élèves et familles
vous vous sentez réellement en danger
dans vos établissements dans vos
fonctions alors complètement rien
qu'aujourd'hui dans mon établissement
est dans ma classe dans une de mes
classes 2,4 collier de et quelques
élèves ont été déclarées qu'à contacter
par la grèce tous les autres étaient
collés à l'élève concerné qui étaient
collés aux autres dans les couloirs dans
les salles dans les escaliers à la
cantine et avec les profs
donc on est tous en danger de cette là
parce qu'on a voulu à tout prix mettre
tous les élèves
dans des salles et des bâtiments exigus
nous demandons depuis quatre mois les
denis groupe 4 mois et en collège ce
n'est pas mieux qu'en lycées donc on ne
comprend pas bien pourquoi le
gouvernement refuse à tout prix j'ai une
info assez exclusive
on a quelqu'un de la rs qui nous a
contactés nous laisserait le rouge pour
nous dire que la demande avait été faite
à la rs ile-de-france d'une micro le
gouvernement a refusé obstinément voilà
où on en est on a aucun dialogue
possible avec ce ministre il veut nous
envoyer attraper le coup livide
il ne nous protège pas et ne protège pas
les enfants il ne protège pas les
familles où on est en danger c'est pour
ça qu'on porte plainte et on n'est pas
entendu donc il nous reste la grève mais
qu'est ce que veut dire la grève ça veut
dire que demain je vais perdre du
salaire pour faire le gouffre du
gouvernement c'est à dire me défendre
défendre les élèves défendent leur
famille du bolide ça va me coûter de
l'argent
hubert salahin vous partagez cet avis
relais récents précise en la rangeant
son régionale de santé un ministre
apparemment d'après nicolas glières qui
est sourd aux demandes vous partagez cet
avis les conditions sanitaires ne sont
pas réunies dans les établissements
scolaires les conditions sanitaires ne
sont pas très bonnes dans les
établissements scolaires on est comme
c'est le cas dans toute la société
je pense que j'ai tout le monde le sait
course je vais chercher son pain poilâne
eux il n'y a pas d'endroit profiter dans
la société et je pense que le lycée sont
comme des collèges sont notamment pas le
pire des endroits si les protocoles sans
respect et correctement si elle gèle
cyril à demain si à des nettoyages en
condition suffisante sur utilise tous
les moyens possibles car les choses
alors on va pas on va pas là vous le
l'enseignant par des qu'il fallait
depuis quatre mois être à 50% mais le
sait sont les élèves qui vont payer
d'arrivée parce que on va le faire
croire que les élèves à 50% du temps
dans l'établissement ils vont avoir les
mêmes apprentissage et la leçon qu'on a
eue au printemps justement c'est que les
professeurs sont indispensables à leur
place une case a besoin d'un professeur
a besoin d'un professeur qui ne fasse
pas simplement un cours en vidéo mais
qui circulent dans sa classe qui
explique aux élèves qui les interactions
voilà donc effectivement c'est pas
facile mais la vie
et confortable pour personne en ce
moment et encore moins pour les élèves
et les élèves ont leur façon dans les
études ils sont en difficulté en
détresse psychologique elle et que ses
poulains c'est une situation compliquée
parce qu'on comprend les uns comme les
autres qui sont dans des situations
difficiles vous voyez faire la grimace
quand nicolas guillou devises et voilà
on n'est pas entendus par par ce
gouvernement bat pas du tout ce
gouvernement met en danger les familles
les élèves les professeurs les
personnels administratifs dans un
aveuglement idéologique totale
un aveuglement même volontaire quand on
écoute jean michel blanquer dans les
interviews qu'il donne dans les médias
français
on a l'impression que tout va bien il
nous sort des chiffres d'un chapeau 3500
élèves qui auraient été contaminés des
chiffres qui sont faut évidemment il
fait croire que les protocoles sont mis
en place
enfin c'est quand même incroyable et
j'espère que la population française
sera à vent debout derrière les
professeurs pour les défendre dans la
façon qu'ils ont de vouloir défendre et
les élèves aient eux-mêmes devant ce
gouvernement irresponsable
la rentrée de septembre n'a pas été
préparée du tout aujourd'hui jean michel
blanquer se réveille trois mois plus
tard pour essayer de préparer finalement
ce qui aurait dû être mis en place
durant l'été mais on a vu que durant
l'été jean michel blanquer avait autre
chose à faire que préparer la rentrée
le problème il est là c'est qu'on a un
gouvernement qui fait semblant de gérer
cette crise sanitaire et qui ne fait
rien que gérer les conséquences pénales
qu'ils pourraient avoir parce qu'ils
sont responsables
et aujourd'hui on voit bien ça s'active
ça commence un peu à bouger
sarr confine parce que oui il ya
plusieurs plaintes au pénal contre les
ministres contre d'anciens ministres et
contre même l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe
donc oui ce gouvernement a été nulle
depuis mars dont la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire et particulièrement dans
ce nouveau confinement qui n'en est pas
un mélissa date de confinement posé à
pardonner gala voilà l'impératif
économique parce que
voilà ça semble être un gros monde enfin
canton mais voilà les les les enfants à
la maison c'est compliqué tout
simplement pour les parents de
travailler mais mais c'est pas compliqué
pour le gouvernement d'empêcher les
petits commerçants de travailler de
faire fermer les commerces de faire
fermer des rayons soi disant non
essentiels dans les grandes surfaces le
la façon dont cette crise est gérée
totalement ubuesque fait que de toute
façon
l'économie va être mis en miettes par ce
nouveau confinement
aujourd'hui on est dans une économie
zombie un massivement subventionné avec
des milliards d'argent de la bce pour
faire croire que tout va bien pour payer
du chômage partiel mais en 2021 si
l'activité ne reprend pas et elle ne
reprendra pas elle ne peut pas reprendre
dans ce cadre actuel du coc vide
eh bien nous aurons là les faillites
réel donc ça m'embête pas le
gouvernement de créer de la faillite
d'un côté alors pourquoi faudrait-il que
les enfants aillent à l'école pour
soutenir l'activité économique puisque
de toute façon cette activité économique
pour de nombreux concitoyens elle est
rétamer elle est finie donc non il y à
là je crois à un aveuglement idéologique
grave parce que aujourd'hui si le
gouvernement est criante et ce serait la
santé des français et ce serait donc
organisé un confinement efficace ou des
mesures efficaces et pour cela je ne
vois pas pourquoi les écoles seraient
ouvertes autre chose on a parlé de
l'enseignement à distance
rien n'a été fait par l'éducation
nationale pour organiser l'équipement et
des familles et des établissements pour
que les établis et que un enseignement à
distance de qualité puisse avoir lieu
donc oui il est surtout extrêmement dago
gilles inégal importe quel prix alors on
pour savoir de quoi on parle on va
regarder les chiffres de santé publique
france le dernier bulletin
épidémiologique qui est datée du 15
octobre dernier il ya effectivement des
interrogations regarder en milieu
scolaire et universitaire 12500 96 khz à
814 cluster au total nicolas guerre est
ce que vous avez des chiffres précis
parce que ça ce sont des chiffres
effectivement mais mais le nombre de
professeurs vraiment malade parce qu'on
le sait on le répète quand même
suffisamment et les médecins les
premiers ce virus n'est pas un danger à
priori pour les enfants
fort heureusement
combien de professeurs touché parce que
c'est ça la vraie question aujourd'hui
alors sur le sur une page notre groupe
facebook les stylos rouges
on a beaucoup de professeurs qui
témoignent avoir une cousine de l'avoir
encore en ce moment là vous rattraper à
l'école au collège ou lycée pour
l'argument des enfants qui seraient plus
mal à faire un un cours à jour sur deux
en demi groupe donc je rétorque vraiment
quelque chose il faut que les parents
nous entende on a besoin de leur soutien
oui ils ont raison il faudrait que les
enfants soient tous les jours à l'école
nous sommes d'accord mais là il ya une
épidémie qui tue qui laissent des
séquelles même aux jeunes et il faut
être raisonnable
il faut que tout le monde fasse un
effort les proches au fond je suis
désolé de le dire c'est peut-être dur
entend mener quel paquet lequel est
forte pour les parents pour le moment
aucun donc là il ya quelque chose à
faire on va on va peut-être donner la
parole justement à la fédération des
parents d'élèves par sosa pas été un
moment spécialement facile le
confinement avec l'école à la maison
et là j'entends dire que les parents ne
font aucun effort n'est pas possible il
ya des gens qui ont perdu la moitié de
leurs revenus ans pas que ce soit le cas
des enseignants d'avrillé difficile pour
bien des gens les gens de + entreprises
des commerces les commerces dont vous
parlez leurs parents sont chez nous les
enfants s'il ya les enfants de
commerçants typique et les personnes qui
ont perdu leur travail
il ya des personnes qui avaient des
petits boulots qui faisait des ménages
dans les hôtels qui ont perdu leur
travail et qui sont des parents d'élèves
alors dire que c'est facile pour les
parents c'est insultant ses auditeurs et
je pense que parfois que vous dites être
raisonnable des fois il raisonnable ccc
se lancer courageusement les fers de
chance de mieux qu'au plus elle
raisonnable c'est pas forcément se dire
tout le monde rentre chez soi
votre boulanger il est raisonnable
quantifier les pins matin aux
commerçants qui sont raisonnables quand
ils travaillent les gens qui font
fonctionner tous les services publics
sont raisonnables la personne qui va
être à la station service ou dans les
magasins il est raisonnable il fait son
travail et il s'engage et aujourd'hui la
vie n'est pas confortable le depor
personnel n'est pas pour les parents en
plus contrairement ce que vous dites
ce qui est quand même très irrespectueux
et qui est vraiment un manque de
considération pour les parents
effectivement c'est difficile pour les
professeurs nous on se rend bien compte
c'est très difficile mais nous par
exemple ce qu'on dit c'est que si les
régions si les départements avaient fait
les efforts de 2,3 personnes en + 4/5
personnes en plus dans les
établissements pour faire du nettoyage
pour fluidifier les choses à la cantine
si on avait permis toutes sortes
d'aménagement comme ça on aurait pu
passer au niveau du confinement
voilà on va avoir des données va qui il
va manquer plusieurs mois de cours
certains ses élèves de 3e par exemple
qui n'ont pas eu cours pendant quatre
mois qui sont rentrés au lycée il peut y
avoir des plans pour les nuls pour les
envies empêcher qui coule et ben la
voilà on va de s'écouler se dédouble et
nicolas glières nicolas lez arras et
voilà ces petits piques que vous envoie
cette bonne guerre on est là pour
débattre
la fédération des parents d'élèves vous
répondez quoi parce que je crois que
demain vous demandez aussi l'extension
de ce protocole sanitaire aux collèges
et aux primaires tout à fait je répète
ce que j'ai dit nous donnons dont le
demi groupe ça veut dire que les élèves
ont cours un jour sur deux par exemple
et l'autre demi journée nous demandons
depuis quatre mois que dès que les
collectivités locales les prennent en
charge
quand les parents ne peuvent pas les
garder deuxième joue ce n'est pas du
tout ce qu'on a dit deuxième n'ont aucun
élève n'a pas eu cours pendant quatre
mois c'est un mensonge tout simplement
nous avons fait cours à distance aux
questions parmi les seuls à travailler
donc je veux dire à le dire quand même
avec les personnels soignants il faut
quand même pas dire n'importe quoi ça
c'est irrespectueux justement les élèves
n'ont pas perdu quatre mois de course
est un mensonge absolu de le dire et
c'est insultant pour l'intégralité du
corps enseignant qui a bossé pendant ce
temps là nous n'étions pas payé nous ne
tuons pas de pda rester chez nous nous
étions payés à travailler ça il faut
vraiment insister pour le dire parce que
le prof bashing à deux semaines du
meurtre de sa belle pâti tout le monde
avait la larme à l'oeil
là encore deux semaines aujourd'hui on
se lâche un journaliste de france
culture vous un peu là c'est un peu
limite
on demande de deux micros voilà on est
on vous êtes forcément d'avis différents
on est là pour débattre
et on essaye de modérée sur le plateau
tout à fait nous ce qu'on demande c'est
ce demi groupes et concrètement ça
permettrait que les élèves ne soient
plus en danger les uns avec les autres
aucun protocole ne peut fonctionner en
classe entière avec l'intégralité des
élèves c'est juste du bon sens et c'est
pour ça qu'on demande l'appui des
parents parce que c'est du bon sens pour
tout le monde quel est le seul moyen
d'empêcher la fermeture des
établissements qu'on ne veut pas que les
parents ne veulent pas que nous ne
voulons pas celle de mes groupes pour
tous et ça il faut vraiment l'entendre
moi je sais plus comment le dire on ne
sait plus comment le désert alors il ya
la grève c'est sur la logique qui a les
chiffres aussi comment le coup vite va
ralentir si des clusters que sur les
écoles collèges lycées restent ouverts
en intégrable avec tous les élèves qui
pullulent avec le coït concrètement dans
les classes des classes pas assez
nettoyer elle devrait pour être efficace
et nettoyer chaque heure est ce possible
non absolument pas en classe entière
donc voilà c'est factuel c'est ce que je
vis au quotidien je peux en témoigner je
peux vous le dire
alex n'est pas possible d'empêcher la
contamination avec les écoles ouvertes à
100% quand jean-michel à blancardi c'est
à chaque lycée de s'adapter il est pas
là justement le problème c'est que dans
le fond chaque directeur d'établissement
se retrouve avec ses responsabilités ce
qui crée effectivement voilà des
détentions le sang elles sont bien
légitimes des deux parts et d'autres
complètement alors ça c'est une des
grandes grandes obsessions de blogueurs
monsieur blanquer on a énormément
d'ailleurs et il veut à tout prix faire
du local toujours en fait tous des
composés tout enlever au niveau national
c'est son dogme libéral
concrètement il veut tout libéraliser et
c'est ce à quoi on assiste alors en gros
il a plus de règles nationales
il ya plus de règles communes on est en
république la règle doit être commune
pour tous
alexis poulain justement sur cette
accusation de libre de vouloir être trop
libérale de la part de jean-michel
blanquer
jean michel blanquer refait ce que fait
le reste du gouvernement c'est-à-dire
qui détricote l'état ils organisent la
faillite de l'état
l'éducation nationale c'est un trésor
c'est ce qui fait pour beaucoup la
république on en a parlé longuement
suite à la décapitation de samuel pâtit
on comprend bien l'importance de cette
éducation nationale même si eric ciotti
voudrais que tout le monde soit dans le
même moule c'est pas ça à l'éducation
nationale s'est donné à chaque citoyen
chaque jeune de france
les moyens de réaliser ce qu'il est
réellement de réaliser son destin et
pour ça c'est la culture c'est le savoir
et c'est à l'école qu'on la prend donc
c'est extrêmement important et ce que
fait jean michel blanquer eh bien il
déconstruit l'école avec il gère la
pénurie exactement comme à l'hôpital on
demande aux soignants de faire
l'impossible et de gérer la pénurie
quand les soignants demande des moyens
on leur répond non il faut vous
organiser autrement
et puis on va pas faire de la dette
alors la dette on en fait beaucoup en ce
moment parce qu'il faut sauver les
banques il faut sauver l'économie
mais non il va aussi falloir sauver
l'éducation nationale sauver l'hôpital
et pour ça c'est quoi c'est plus de
professeurs c'est plus de médecins plus
de soignants c'est des gens qui vont
être formés pour être face aux élèves
face aux malades et s'est arrêté avec ce
n'est au management de la terreur du dos
de la feuille excel de dudu du profit
parce que c'est ça que fait jean michel
bancaire gérer la pénurie et faire que
les colts soit rentable non un service
public il n'est pas là pour être
rentable et le néo management public qui
est à la manoeuvre depuis une trentaine
d'années a atteint sa limite c'est à
dire qu'on a vendu l'état incapable
incapable de fournir des services
publics incapables aussi de gérer une
crise majeure comme celle du co vide
regardez simplement l'état de faillite
dans lequel on se trouve
parce que nos élites nos chers élus font
croire qu'ils gèrent la crise mais non
ils gèrent simplement leurs
communications personnelles et le risque
pénal face à cette mauvaise gestion de
la crise parce que l'état est
aujourd'hui incapable de faire face à
une crise comme celle ci est incapable
de faire que l'école soit de qualité et
ben salah là on a un petit peu débordé
le cadre de la gestion de l'épidémie par
par l'école l'enfant sur ces critiques
de la part de l'éducation nationale vous
justement en tant que fédération des
parents d'élèves nous avez quelle
qu'elle veut
on est tellement on fait ce qu'on peut
sur sur le terrain avec les moyens du
bord ce sera tout le monde sait toujours
ce qu'il peut avec les moyens du bord
voilà après il ya les moyens imaginaire
ou des moyens rêver voilà si on les a
pas il faut bien travailler après l'âge
on ne va pas remettre sur sur cette
question là toute la politique qui a été
fait par rapport au niveau éducation
nationale depuis depuis plus de trois
ans maintenant
mais là quand j'entendais par exemple
l'enseignant dire que que qu'il faut
quelque chose de national qu'il faut pas
des solutions locales avec des
proviseurs mais nous quand ce sont les
professeurs qui sont dans leur classe et
qui ont leur liberté pédagogique on les
approuvent
justement quand ils disent qu'il ne faut
pas seulement la solution nationale avec
des choses qui descendent directement de
ministères avec des consignes fait
l'autre corps comme ceux ci comme cela
nous fait confiance aux enseignants
quand ils sont dans leurs classes qui
sont ceux qui connaissent le mieux leur
zèle ils ont la liberté pédagogique et
ils font leur travail
on n'a pas besoin ce mandat d'avoir le
ministre qui leur dit quoi faire donc il
ya des moments il faut effectivement des
choses au niveau national mais on fait
aussi confiance au terrain on fait aussi
confiance aux professeurs ont fait aussi
confiance au provisionnement mes
collègues d'hier
le mot de la fin ça n'a juste aucun
rapport en fait la liberté pédagogique
c'est faire confiance aux enseignants
que nous sommes parce qu'on adore qu'on
a recrutés sur un concours difficile
pour enseigner pour transmettre nos
savoirs aux élèves
là on parle d'une crise sanitaire
majeure international et on parle d'une
épidémie qui est dangereuse pour tout le
monde je voudrais aussi ajouter
rapidement par rapport à ce que votre
bandeau malheureusement ça ne concerne
pas du tout où les lycées justement
monsieur blanc qu'un ne voulais pas que
ça soit du tout mis en place il a fini
par vaguement cédé pour quelques lycées
en fait c'est aucun lycée pro déjà il
faut le savoir
et ça doit concerner 400 à 500 mille
élèves au maximum
donc ce n'est pas vrai il ya 12 millions
et demi des lèvres en france ce n'est
pas tous les lycées du tout il s'est
arrangé pour que ce soit le moins
possible vraiment nous demandons à ce
que ce soit étendue partout primaire
collège lycée pour la sécurité de tout
le monde dans une bonne intelligence
avec des cours à distance des cours en
présence pour le bien des élèves pour le
nôtre pour celui des femmes nées pour la
santé de tous c'est le seul moyen de
sortir de cette épidémie c'est une
certitude
des médecins disent troupes en france
énormément à l'étranger merci en tout
cas à tous les trois une berce alain
nicolas glières alexis poulain d'avoir
été avec non d'avoir accepté ce débat
merci à vous et la crise du pot vide n'a
pas que des répercussions sur la
mortalité et les domaines hospitalier
économique de nombreuses études
l'attestent la pandémie altère la santé
mentale des français à tel point que de
nombreux professionnels de la
psychologie ou de la psychiatrie alerte
sur le manque de moyens
or les prendre en charge un sujet signé
quatre ça pique nique avec nicolas coupé
à cause de la pandémie et du confinement
le bien-être des français se détériore
depuis mars dernier
plus d'un millier d'études ont évalué
cette détresse psychologique due à
l'enfermement chez soi à la solitude à
l'incertitude en juin ont noté une
augmentation des dépressions du fait des
conséquences psychiatrique du
confinement les violences faites aux
femmes se sont multipliées les étudiants
confinés dans de petits logements
éloignés de leurs amis incapable de se
projeter dans l'avenir ont été
particulièrement touchés par cette
situation inédite selon l'étude une
équipe de chercheurs du centre inserm
bordeaux population lgbt 28 % des
étudiants se déclarent triste déprimé ou
désespéré plus de la moitié du temps
voir tous les jours contre 15 % chez les
non étudiants un psychologue
hélène romano a participé à la
commission d' enquête initiée par la
députée communiste marie george buffet
afin de mesurer prévenir les effets de
la crise du coc vite sur la jeunesse
elle détaille les conséquences du
confinement sur la santé mentale
on a beaucoup de demandes dans des
contextes roubles à peine anxieux de
phobie sociale de jean propre peur de
sortir on peut attraper le virus et
consoles plus que d'habitude de l'alcool
des psychotropes des billets et des
drogues cannabis donc on a plus de
troubles psychiques
en temps normal le psychiatre nicolas
franck et chefs de pôles au centre
hospitalier le vinatier à lyon a
également travaillé sur ces souffrances
psychiques
il en réfère dans un livre qu vider
détresse psychologique aux éditions
odile jacob
alors que les choses se sont encore
aggravées avec le nouveau confinement
il souhaiterait aujourd'hui que les
pouvoirs publics prennent la mesure de
ce grave problème de santé publique
impose des restrictions extrêmement
important toutes et tous les français
qui ne peuvent plus circuler librement
qu'ils ne peuvent plus se rencontrer
librement hors l'être humain en effet ni
pour être enfermés ni pour être coupé
des autres jeux contre la dimension de
la santé mentale est extrêmement
importante parce que là on touche tous
les français ont contraint tous les
français on leur impose une épreuve qui
est difficile à supporter donc il faut
les accompagner ça veut dire avoir une
communication pour leur permettre de
remarquer des manifestations d'une
certaine difficulté à venir des
dispositifs pour les écouter et ça veut
dire éventuellement des soins appropriés
pour ceux qui en ont besoin
durant le premier confinement un certain
nombre d'initiatives avait été mise en
place par des associations ou par l'état
des plateformes téléphoniques d' écoutes
avait été ouverte
les consultations en psychiatrie dédié
au co vide existe toujours mais pour le
reste très peu de projets dans le
domaine ont été créés ou reconduits
hélène romano tire la sonnette d'alarmé
liait des des lieux pour les parents ont
le soutien à la parentalité ça c'est
extrêmement important pour aider les
parents à repérer les troupes savoir
comment à parler avec leurs enfants
et concrètement qu'il y ait des
possibilités gratuite c'est très
important pour les parents les
enseignants et éventuellement d'avoir au
moins des plateformes téléphoniques ou
des structures d'accueil sur la question
des conséquences du confinement
pour l'instant ça n'existe pas au pays
des bisounours il faudrait des moyens un
pour les psy c'est à dire plus de petits
seins recruté deux petits gars de
présomption de psychologue c'est pas du
tout la volonté actuelle vraiment des
lieux d'exil avec des professionnels
formés mi août un rapport d' analyse du
ministère de la santé avait pourtant
pointé les immenses besoins qui sont nés
durant la crise et les très nombreux
domaines république qui nécessite des
compétences en santé mentale
maintenant il s'agirait de traduire les
intentions en actes et un vaccin contre
le coran navires us efficace à 90% ce
serait en tout cas le cas selon lé
laboratoire américain pfizer et biotech
les deux géants pharmaceutiques ont
effectué des tests sur 44 mille
personnes leur vaccin sans est en phase
3 du protocole d'essai
le dernier avant une demande
d'homologation les entreprises ont
déclaré qu'elle prévoyait de fournir
jusqu'à 50 millions de doses dans le
monde dès 2020 un espoir après une
longue bataille a déclaré joe biden
futur président des états unis
de son côté donald trump a salué une
excellente nouvelle
l'union européenne précise elle qu'elle
va finaliser bientôt son contrat avec
pfizer biotech pour acheter jusqu'à 300
millions donc de doses dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous partirons
aux états unis justement que joe biden
commence le processus de transition sans
attendre que donald trump reconnaisse sa
défaite et puis nous parlerons la lutte
contre le terrorisme france autriche
allemagne et union européenne cerneront
mardi un mini sommet virtuel pour tenter
d'y apporter une réponse
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême du
musée la donation
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île vers view
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme je monte sur les pas en
appartement on est énervé donnait le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément au loin
de paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui
les dirigent
moi je veux pas qu'on me fasse un tour
de tracteur et cnooc est en campagne il
faut savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci nous rejoindre 20h30 heure
de paris
les supporters de joe biden ont fêté ce
week-end les nonces de la victoire de
leur candidat pourtant ces résultats ne
sont pas encore officiels l'équipe de
donald trump ne concède pas sa défaite
et continue de pointer des irrégularités
dans le scrutin
elle nous retrouvons en direct de
washington notre reporter thomas abonnés
bonsoir thomas alors où on est on est ce
qu'on a du nouveau oui malgré les scènes
de liesse qui ont eu lieu ce week-end
notamment dans la ville de washington où
je me trouve où plusieurs milliers de
personnes se sont rassemblées joe biden
n'est pas encore officiellement le
président élu des etats unis la raison
est toute simple il ya des recours
juridiques qui ont été déposés par
l'équipe de donald trump cela concerne
en fait 6 et à la pennsylvanie le
michigan l'arizona le nevada la géorgie
et le wiz consignes plusieurs types d'
irrégularités sont avancées par l'équipe
de campagne de donald trump des bugs de
logiciels des bulletins comptés après la
date butoir ou encore des votes qui
seraient issus des lecteurs morts
il va falloir que l'équipe juridique
apporte des preuves a tout cela
évidemment mais ces éventuelles preuves
doivent aussi apporter permettre
d'appuyer pardon les accusations de
fraude lancées par le président et son
équipe samedi
rudolph giulani a tenu une conférence de
presse je propose d'écouter un extrait
tout d'abord il ne va évidemment pas il
ne va pas reconnaître deux défaites sont
au mois six cent mille bulletins de vote
sont douteux ce n'est pas mon travail de
déterminer si les bulletins sont
corrects union c'est leur travail parce
qu'il s'agit d'un vote par
correspondance ou par procuration la
charge légale incombe aux partis qui le
propose
c'est pourquoi il doit être inspectés
comment pourrais je vous dire s'il ya
fraude et non six recours seront déposés
à partir de lundi
alors que des irrégularités puisse être
relevés dans certains états c'est une
chose reste maintenant à déterminer
surtout à démontrer s'il s'agit d'un
fait à grande échelle et surtout si cela
a pu faire basculer
mathématiquement l'élection au-delà de
ces irrégularités donald trump demande
également le recomptage dans certains
états où l'écart est très serré avec joe
biden la géorgie va recompter est
locataire de la maison blanche souhaite
aussi un recomptage dont le whisky si
nous il n'y a à l'heure actuelle que
vingt mille voix d'écart entre les deux
candidats toutes ces démarches vont donc
ralentir l'annoncé officielle des
résultats la date butoir c'est le 8
décembre
c'est le jour où la liste des grands
électeurs doit être envoyée et six jours
plus tard le collège électoral doit
procéder au vote pour désigner le
prochain président des états unis il
reste donc un peu de temps à donald
trump pour constituer son dossier lui
qui restera quoi qu'il arrive le
président des états unis jusqu'au 20
janvier prochain
merci est un abonné en direct de
washington et pour en parler nous sommes
avec tristan cabello maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
l'université john hopkins à washington
est également bon soir à tristan a qu'à
vélo merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france les médias américains donc
et les dirigeants européens d'ailleurs
qui annoncent la victoire avant le le
recomptage on se souvient qu'en 2000 ont
fait un petit retour en arrière
george bush et al gore s'étaient
affrontées pour une même histoire de
recomptage en floride on avait attendu
trente six jours font savoir que george
bush est élu président c'est pas le même
traitement avec donald trump est ce
qu'on peut comprendre qu'ils disent cela
comme une nonne stx ou non tout à fait
je crois que comme le reporter venait de
le dire il faut quand même rappeler aux
téléspectateurs que aujourd'hui aux
états unis il n'ya pas de président élu
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a absolument
aucun document officiel qui a été donné
par l'administration trump pour rendre
officielle l'élection de joe biden joe
biden doit tête
décréter président élu par emily murphy
qui est en charge des giants services
agency et cette personne a très
clairement dit que l'élection était
clairement contesté et qu'elle ne
pouvait pas donner ce document qui
rendrait donc l'élection de joe biden
officiel j'ai envie de dire finalement
peu importe parce que les résultats de
cette élection sont déjà en demi teinte
pour les deux candidats
c'est à dire qu'on peut se place du
point de vue de donald trump ou du point
de vue de joe biden c'est dans les deux
cas soit une demi-défaite soit une demi
victoire
joe biden on nous l'avait vendu comme le
candidat rassembleur qui devait
effectuer un raz de marée bleue sur
toute l'amérique
il n'en a pas été le cas du tout mais en
plus de ça on peut dire quand même que
son programme n'a pas été vraiment
imprimé par les par les électeurs
américains et de l'autre côté il faut
quand même rappeler que donald trump a
fait une très belle campagne et et que
son score final a été bien plus haut que
le score que les sondages lui donnaient
mais vous qui êtes heures aux états unis
justement quel regard vous portez sur
cette campagne il ya eu selon vous deux
poids deux mesures parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a vu des médias voilà avoir un
traitement quand même
il ne s'en cache pas une fois de plus ça
fait faisant foi je le répète mais c'est
vrai qu'ils ont coupé le président entre
hommes lorsqu'ils voient là il parlait
de fraude à ce que vous avez déjà vu ça
en tant qu'observateur aux états unis
alors il est très clair qu'il ya des
médias qui roule pour trinquer des
médias qui route pour byden la grande
majorité des médias en fait sont pour la
candidature de baden et quelques médias
vraiment à la marge dont fox news dont
brad en fait sens pour la combattre la
candidature de trump j'aimerais dire ça
c'est vraiment très peu d'importance
finalement puisque les trunks a eu peu
d'importance dans cette campagne que ça
n'a pas pesé
oui parce qu'en fait les électeurs de 30
la passe de trois est une base qui est
très solide et qui s'informent en fait
très peu 1 / sur les médias généraux les
médias mainstream
si nbc et msnbc ci et qui s'informent
principalement sur sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire que le vote trump
c'est finalement un vote anti
establishment byden c'était vraiment
l'étendard de l'establishment américain
le vote rome c'était un vote anti bailon
entier etablishment et ces secteurs là
ne s'informent pas sûr sûr sûr les
médias mais monsieur vous l'avait dit en
début de cette interview il va désormais
compliqués enfin en tout cas c'est une
des conséquences de ce que vous avez dit
voilà c'est une victoire en demi teinte
peut-être 71 millions d'électeurs pour
donald trump tout de même il va ça vous
il va falloir maintenant rassemblés pour
un job hayden va-t-il parvenir selon
vous alors joe dalton c'est quelqu'un
qui a inquiété quand même à la tête
d'une coalition très disparates 1 qui
allait de la gauche radicale à la droite
conservatrice et j'en veux dire que je
pense que pour lui ça va déjà être
difficile de rassembler son propre camp
on le voit que déjà depuis l'élection la
gauche radicale c'est à dire bernie
sanders est aussi elizabeth warren
et déjà est déjà en position en position
de lutte contre la droite conservatrice
comme john key sic par exemple pour les
postes principal dans le gouvernement de
dubaï donne donc pour joe biden vraiment
le but principal la c'est de rassembler
son camp avant de pouvoir rassembler
vraiment l'amérique à terme
à quoi doit-on s'attendre justement
décrite cottage total de la politique de
trump qui sentit onyx et chez les
démocrates
alors non on va pas absorber absolument
pas avoir un des micro intégré d'un
détricotage de la politique de trump
pourquoi parce que la cour suprême est
conservatrice et à majorité républicaine
et le sénat est à majorité républicaine
donc qui que ce soit qui arrive à la
maison blanche maiden ou trump
vous savez bayonne sera un président de
cohabitation le sénat restera restera
conservateur restera républicain et donc
il faudra pour buydens composer avec ce
sénat qui est déjà républicain merci
beaucoup tristan est mêlé au maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
l'université john hopkins à washington
merci à vous d'avoir été en direct sur
rt france
[Musique]
apporter une réponse européenne au
terrorisme c'est le but du mini sommet
qui aura lieu par visioconférence demain
à l'initiative d' emmanuel macron il
réunira la france l'autriche l'allemagne
et les dirigeants de l'union européenne
après les derniers attentats qui ont
touché vienne et le territoire français
regardez
[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
la décapitation du professeur samuel
petit l'attentât à la basilique de nice
ou encore la fusillade à vienne la
france et l'europe sont donc confrontés
à une menace terroriste contre laquelle
elles tentent de riposter
quelles réponses peuvent être donné ce
mardi lors du mini sommet place à notre
décryptage en présence tombes de nos
invités et pour en parler nous sommes
avec jean-michel fauvergue député la
république en marge de seine et marne
ancien patron du raid bonsoir jean
michel faubert merci d'être avec nous en
direct à toi sur rt france à vos côtés
thierry orosco ancien patron du gign
bonsoir à vous aussi thierry orosco
merci d'être avec nous on l'a vu donc
qu'un ces derniers jours viennent lice
conflans sainte honorine est les
terroristes qui frappent manifestement
où ils veulent et très rapidement c'est
un électrochoc pour emmanuel macron il
est différent dirigeants européens il y
aura un avant et un après jean michel
fau bac
vous savez un avant et un après c'est
difficile à dire on est sur un on est
sur une évolution sur quelque chose qui
qui demeure la menace la menace demeure
la menace était prégnante en france on
est plus sur une menace de réseau on est
sur une menace de terrorisme endogène
globalement 1
et cette menace cela existe on l'a vu
non seulement en france mais dans
d'autres pays européens votre votre
petit reportage l'a bien démontré donc
c'est quelque chose devant avec qu'elle
ne faut pas baisser les bras et le
sommet qui arrive qui arrive est un
sommet important pour un certain nombre
d'échangés et de mise au point pour une
riposte qui peut dans certains cas être
commune on va en parler de ce mini
sommet mais mais tout d'abord vous dites
c'est vrai vous nous rappeler est
endogène c'est ça toujours été présent
mais c'est vrai il faut bien le dire
qu'on l'avait peut-être un petit peu
oublié cette menace terroriste j'en veux
pour preuve ce sondage seuls 16% des
français l'a jugée élevée en septembre
dernier d'après un sondage ifop
vous diriez thierry orosco qu'on a fermé
temporairement les yeux à cause
peut-être de la crise sanitaire où il y
avait peut-être moins d'actions qu'elle
est réellement l'état de la menace
terroriste au moment où on se parle en
france olav une intériorité melwood
comme je pense qu'il est servi de rooney
détroit est fort bien
il est certain que beaucoup d'attentes
avons été et jouer beaucoup de régions
ont été des mots clés ce qui fait qu'on
a une impression qui ne pas prescrire
messieurs continuez que ont fait menaces
à des crues et les événements récents
moules ou alors cette semaine on va
commémorer
un triste anniversaire évidemment les
cinq ans de la tuerie du bataclan
attaque qui avait fait plus de 230 morts
le 13 novembre 2015 en plein coeur de
paris à cette occasion vous sortez tous
les deux un livre coécrit gign raid de
patrons face aux nouvelles menaces
cette menace terroriste durant ces cinq
ans elle l'a profondément muté
jean michel faubert comment vos services
se sont adaptés et ont coopéré
oui la menace on vient de le dire un
muté on est passé d'une menace de réseau
dans l'année 2015 et en particulier les
attentats de 2,2
le duc de des terrasses et du bataclan
et venez à la fois de l'extérieur et de
l'intérieur c'est une menace de réseau
qui était organisé on est passé de cette
menace là une menace endogène avec des
des terroristes qui vient de notre
propre pays est qui et qui frappent la
france de manière de manière tout à fait
rapide et c'est difficile pour les dents
dans ce cadre là pour les services de
renseignements de pouvoir travailler
dessus mais pour ce qui concerne les
services d'intervention le raid et le
gign
nous avons très tôt et d'ailleurs d'où
l'intérêt de ce livre que vous avez
cités nous avons très tous travaillé
avec thierry sur la menace qu'ils
allaient nous frapper et nous nous
sommes entendus pour mettre au point des
dés
assez rapidement de la possibilité de
nous aider les uns les autres c'est ça
qui est intéressant et nous allons fait
évoluer nos unités dans ce sens là et
ignorance que ce n'était pas le cas
avant on peut s'étonner finalement que
cette initiative
on peut la saluer mais est-ce qu'elle
n'est pas venue trop tard
elle est certainement pas venu dans les
deux unités l'ayant côtoyé ensemble il
n'y avait pas eu de vrai alors le quéau
et demi selon une échelle voudrais vous
me préciser le choc as a évolué c'est
parce que l'adversaire a évolué et s'il
a évolué c'est parce que tu es resté
statique on fait que les précédents
titres ab terroriste était plus possible
le et peu à peu se sont orientés vers un
autre site mais de terrorisme plus
simple plus difficiles à détecter et
peut être moins complexes et moins
organisés les sens forcément moins d'un
10 pour les prévoir mais il faut bien
prendre en compte que cette évolution du
terroriste lui terrorisme est d'abord le
résultat de l'action de la france sur
notre territoire et dans les opérations
extérieures et de la coopération avec
les autres pays
aujourd'hui jean michel fauvergue il ya
ce mini sommet
vous aviez l'air tout à l'heure d'en
attendre beaucoup justement que peut-on
espérer de cette réunion
dans ce cas l'important c'est de ces de
discuter d'échanger d'avoir des des
réactions des techniques communes
peut-être que je dis bien peut-être un
certain moment la france étant touchés
peut-être que d'autres pays européens
ont cru qu'ils étaient à l'abri de ceux
de ce terrorisme là ça n'est pas le cas
ça n'est pas vrai lancé que les
combattants les les gens qui sont partis
combattre avec des ch
était important en france en belgique
mais était aussi substantiellement
important dans certains autres pays et
que européen entre autres et que les
pays européens doivent maintenant avoir
des ripostes commune alors c'est vrai
sur le renseignement
il ya beaucoup d'échangés en termes de
renseignements c'est vrai aussi sur les
unités d'intervention comme le raid le
jijel vous savez que au niveau européen
on a un groupe particulier où tous les
groupes d'intervention se retrouve ce
qui s'appelle le groupe atlas nous y
représentions la france avec 6 euros ce
qu il y avait à la fois le le reggie
jeunes qui étaient représentés donc tout
ça est très très important de continuer
à travailler sur cette menace là au
niveau du renseignement au niveau des
enquêtes au niveau de l'intervention
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
nécessaire thierry orosco aujourd'hui
quelle est la principale faiblesse en
france dans cette lutte contre le
terrorisme selon vous l'ophlm quoiqu'il
faiblesses structurelles fondamentales
je pense simplement que chaque fois on
attend arrive les services
d'intervention comme les services
funèbres on se pose la question est ce
que j'avais vu quelque chose que je n'ai
pas eu identifier est ce qu'il y avait à
ce qu'il y à faibles qui ont échappé
pour les unités d'intervention celi mode
d'action est ce que je pouvais le
contrer et si demain ils se battent au
nom de les faire plus efficace
on voit aujourd'hui que ça ne concerne
pas simple pour les unités du héros du
titre et le gign et le raid
mais ce concerne que l'on appelle les
primes aux intervenantes des
représentants des forces de l'ordre
car met sur la voie publique le meilleur
exemple avec alice celles improvisées
municipal qui est intervenu montré que
les agents de sécurité représentant
or ce public sont importants pour lutter
l'interroger on colle terrorisme même
question formulée autrement jean michel
fau verve aujourd'hui quels sont les
points qu'on a peut-être le plus
amélioré sur le sol français pour éviter
ce genre d'actions qui ne sont pas
commises
justement que par défoncer ou sauzier
allusion voilà en fait il y avait des
français qui commettaient des attentats
mais ce n'était pas le cas dans dans les
dernières attaques
écoutez il faut il faut améliorer
toujours et toujours et encore notre
vigilance dans ces domaines là c'est
quelque chose d'absolument important
mais vous savez autant on s'aperçoit
dans l'attentât quand il a lieu autant
le disais tout à l'heure thierry c'est
difficile de rendre grâce aux services
de renseignement et aux services
d'intervention est au service des
enquêtes d'attentats déjoués et pourtant
il y en a eu quelques-uns est de ce
point de vue là les services l'ensemble
des services français travaillent plutôt
bien maintenant ce qui ce qu'on est en
train d'essayer de devoir c'est là une
meilleure coopération sur le terrain
même au quotidien dans la sécurité du
quotidien mais qui travaille aussi pour
pour les sur les signes faible du du
terrorisme meilleure coopération à la
fois avec des services de la police et
la gendarmerie nationale d'un côté avec
les services de police municipale voir
avec des services de sécurité privés
dans leur domaine de compétence et c'est
ce que nous sommes en train de porter en
ce moment au parlement avec une loi qui
est une loi sur la sécurité globale
ça c'est quelque chose d'important aussi
j'allais y venir justement cette loi
elle sera discutée le 17 novembre
prochain par les députés taxant lequel
vous faites la proposition de limiter la
diffusion l'image des forces de l'ordre
claire guesdon à la défenseure des
doigts pointe du doigt je la cite des
risques considérables sur la liberté
d'informer et le droit à la vie privée
même son de cloche du côté du snj je
vous propose d'écouter avant de vous
faire réagir la proposition de loi dite
de sécurité globale déposée par la
majorité gouvernement
total entend interdire la diffusion par
tout moyen de l'image d'un policier d'un
gendarme ou d'un militaire en opération
dans le but de porter atteinte à leur
intégrité physique ou psychique
ce texte est une réponse clientéliste du
ministère de l'intérieur à la plupart
des syndicats de police ce texte vise
également à empêcher la révélation
d'affaires de violences policières
illégitimes souvent dissimulées par la
hiérarchie des fonctionnaires en cause
comme ce fut le cas dans les affaires de
geneviève le gué et de cédric joue via
vous fait pas que des amis à jean michel
faubert vous estimez vous allez trop
loin
quelle est votre réponse à ces critiques
écoutez si j'estimais qu'on allait trop
loin on n'aurait pas rédigé le texte
comme il est rédigé la caisse qui dit ce
texte ce texte il est fait pour protéger
ce qui nous protège protéger nos
policiers protégés une aux gendarmes qui
sont aux premières aux premières loges
protéger aussi les pompiers nous sommes
sûrs sur un texte en réalité ce texte
dit que le fait de diffuser les images
d'un policier dans le but
dans le but de de porter atteinte à son
intégrité physique et psychique et un
est un délit alors il s'adresse aux gens
qui vont qui vont essayer de commettre
ce délit
il s'adresse bien évidemment pas mais
absolument pas aux journalistes et
n'empêche pas de faire le travail des
journalistes en réalité ce texte un
texte pour pour protéger nos policiers
et nos gendarmes qui ont été sévèrement
attaquées ces derniers temps dont les
familles ont été attaqués certains
policiers certains gendarmes ont dû
demander des mutations parce que sur les
réseaux sociaux ils étaient harcelés et
ils risquent leur vie donc c'est ce
texte sert à ça c'est un texte pour
défendre les policiers et c'est pas un
texte contre qui que ce soit autre
proposition étendre les pouvoirs
judiciaires des polices municipales
thierry orosco vous êtes en face
justement avec cette recommandation et
jusqu'où augmenter les pouvoirs de la
police municipale on sait qu'il ya eu ce
débat sur le port d'armes
réponse je suis tout à fait pour
l'accompagner évidemment d'une formation
il faut il encadrer par la loi s'est
fait jean-michel de salut mais comment
peut-on ignorer le nombre des policiers
municipaux armés en france ok on
refuserait le droit de participer à la
sécurisation des français alors que des
actes terroristes parce que penserait et
amis des victimes
si tel n'était pas le cas comme ancien
commandant du gign
j'aurais aimé avoir une loi à la fois
pour protéger les gendarmes qui
travaillait sous mes ordres mais aussi
eu d' harvey cet effet de surprise que
vous savez on pas toujours en direct des
opérations je pense à l'assaut de
l'avion à marignane qui est célèbre
je pense à la sobre et de licata cher il
ya autant de faits dont on sait très
bien qu'ils peuvent également servir des
touristes pendant l'action pour contrer
les forces de l'ordre tout ce qui va
dans ce sens là bien entendu son jubilé
la presse est de nature à emporter tout
la vision et je lis si jean michel qui
est un connaisseur du sujet de porter
une telle loi un jean-michel la favela
mot de la fin pour vous que tu es le mot
de la fin je sais c'est difficile à dire
je pense que là en ce moment on est on
est un peu dans avec ma collègue alice
taureau qui avec qui nous pourtant la
loi enl un peu dans la seringue
on va
en est en train d'étudier tous les
amendements qui nous sont portés on
étudie tous au mot près pour faire une
loi équilibré qui va servir non
seulement a beaucoup parlé de la
protection des ce qui nous protège c'est
vrai mais qui va surtout servir et ça
c'est notre notre devise est notre notre
manière d'être avec terry roscoe c'est
pour ça qu'on a fait ce livre sur le
real et sur les gènes qui va surtout
servir la protection des français notre
but c'est d'avoir une meilleure
protection pour tous les français les
françaises et les français sur le
territoire national et ceux qui ne sont
pas français sur le territoire national
mais qui vivent sur notre territoire
national
mais je m'appelle le titre de ce livre
gign raid de fès de patrons face aux
nouvelles menaces aux éditions baroque
merci à tous les deux d'avoir été en
direct sur l'antenne d'arte et france
jean-michel fauvergue héritier lee rose
co merci à vous restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
commerçants touchés de plein fouet par
la crise du corona virus l'inquiétude
grandit parmi eux notamment à lyon alors
qu'ils sont fermés depuis le second film
en vue direction la bolivie où l'ex
président morales est entré
après un an d'exil forcé au lendemain de
l'investiture de luis arce est devenu
président à son tour
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inné gilet jaune c'était
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pau
et pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sourires
elles ont eu la prétention de croire que
les valeurs qu'elle défend des est
imposé par la force dans leur conquête
était universel dans cette terre des
possibles où s'esquissent les figures du
monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant co management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que moi c'est fini pour moi est
ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'information
il est 21h heure française tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 9 novembre une semaine après
l'entrée en vigueur du confinement le
protocole sanitaire renforcée dans les
vices et les établissements sont invités
à diminuer la promiscuité via un accueil
en demi groupe ares niveau et en
recourant au travail à distance
ce protocole jugé insuffisant par
plusieurs syndicats qui appellent à la
grève demain
côté nouvelles encourageantes un vaccin
contre le corona bo serait efficace à
90% c'est ce qu'annonce en tout cas
aujourd'hui et laboratoire américain
pfizer et biotech
après un an d'exil
evo morales de retour dans son pays
natal l'ancien président bolivien avait
quitté le pays sous la pression de
l'armée et de la police
et après des manifestations
ininterrompues un retour qui intervient
au lendemain d'investiture de son
dauphin luis arce et à la présidence
cette figure tutélaire de la gauche
bolivienne l'assurent il ne compte pas
revenir en politique
[Musique]
justin trudeau ou angela merkel emmanuel
macron tous se félicitent joe biden dans
sa victoire annoncée par les médias
américains la chine et la russie préfère
attendre les résultats officiels
si donald trump 1 n'a pas encore
présenté des éléments de preuve
d'éventuelles fraudes le scrutin est il
pour autant déjà terminé ce sera l'objet
d'offres face à face tout à fait le
break si tu as les négociations entre le
royaume uni et l'union européenne ont
repris aujourd'hui toujours avec
l'espoir de surmonter les divergences
comme sur le droit de la pêche et les
garanties exigées par bruxelles
or une concurrence non faussée des
discussions alors que le temps presse
pour encadrer les relations entre les
deux blocs
après la fin
31 décembre de la période de transition
qui a suivi la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne
[Musique]
m
et on débute avec les derniers chiffres
du corona virus en france jérôme selle
au mans le directeur général de la santé
dénombre vingt mille cent cinquante cinq
nouveaux cas de contamination kovy dans
24 heures cinq cent cinquante et une
personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital ces
dernières 24 heures et 4690 patients
sont en réanimation et les mesures
sanitaires ont des conséquences majeures
pour les petits commerçants on en a
souvent parlé les initiatives se
multiplient pour alerter sur les
difficultés traversées par ces
indépendants comme à lyon ce lundi où
plusieurs centaines d'entre eux se sont
réunis devant la préfecture louis
cabello avec robin pu l
laissez nous travailler un mot d'ordre
lancé comme un cri d'alarmé par les
commerçants lyonnais ce lundi à l'appel
de plusieurs organisations
près de 200 indépendance se sont réunis
devant la préfecture du rhône pour
alerter sur la situation critique à
laquelle ils sont confrontés
ils protestent notamment contre la
fermeture de leur établissement malgré
les efforts consentis pour appliquer les
protocoles sanitaires
les manifestants souhaitent attirer
l'attention du gouvernement
j'espère que le premier ministre et
l'ensemble du gouvernement ainsi que le
président d'un public prenne enfin
conscience
nous avons fait nous allons appliquer
toutes les sensations qui était imposé
nous avons respecté les règles je ne
vois pas pourquoi nous aurions
diaboliser à ce point là après plus de
deux mois d'inactivité lors de la
première mise sous cloche du pays
l'activité peine à redémarrer pour ces
commerçants indépendants
face à l'incertitude générée par le
contexte sanitaire certains n'ont pas pu
rouvrir leurs établissements entre les
de confinement une situation qui menace
la survie de nombreux professionnels
la fermeture des établissements abbas
est plus qu'une possibilité c'est à dire
que si ce confinement dur
tous ces professionnels qui aujourd'hui
sont fermés son chiffre d'affaires ne
vont pas pouvoir tenir et c'est pas les
mesures qui sont prises
même si je reconnais qu'on est dans un
pays où on a beaucoup de chance qu'ils
vont suffire à tenir la tête hors de
l'eau de tous est indépendant et cinq
mois c'est très très dur
j'assistais 35 ans de travail qui
partent en fumée
mais là je suis certainement pas le seul
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a un bon petit
nombre malgré le confinement
et puis c'est pas fini on reviendra
toutes les semaines s'il faut aller dans
ce plus dur on dira donc plus dur bien
plus que ça pour sauver nos entreprises
une délégation de commerçants lyonnais a
déjà été reçu la semaine dernière par le
chef de cabinet du préfet de région
mais la mobilisation se poursuit pour
sauver leurs activités avec la proche de
la période de noël est essentielle pour
la grande majorité d'entre eux les
indépendants attendent un geste fort de
la part du gouvernement et pour en
parler nous sommes avec pascal mons et
restaurateurs et président du génie
paris ile de france qui représente donc
les indépendants de l'hôtellerie et de
la restauration bonsoir pascal mousset
merci d'être avec nous on a vu vos
collègues lyonnais allaient manifester
se battre dans la rue
vous pensez que ça va porter ses fruits
de faire entendre la colère est ce que
vous croyez encore possible une
réouverture le 12 novembre comme vous
l'appeliez de vos voeux il ya quelques
temps encore en fait on l'espère
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voudrait c'est
avoir des perspectives c'est vrai que 12
novembre on n'est pas très nombreux et y
croire parce que traditionnellement avec
cette crise sanitaire on a appris à être
les premiers à fermer les restaurants et
avec les derniers à rouvrir
parce que l'argument sanitaire qui nous
est invoquée c'est qu'il faut retirer le
masque pendant le la prestation que ce
soit dans un bar ou dans un restaurant
aujourd'hui ce qu'il nous faut c'est des
perspectives on peut pas rester comme ça
cinq mois ferme et et n'avoir aucune
perspective
aucune date ne pas savoir comment
organiser ces fêtes de fin d'année si
nos restaurants seront fermées pendant
les fêtes et se trouve aidera la merci
économiquement de nos créanciers des
banques des bailleurs des assureurs de
tout ce qui tourne et qui qui en fait on
devient une proie et ont deux
extrêmement fragilisée avec ses cinq
mois d'absence de chiffre d'affaires et
surtout aucune perspective
aucune entreprise ne peut survivre sans
avoir l'espoir une date un moment où
elle va pouvoir réenclencher une
activité ça quand vous l'expliquait très
clairement parce que ça semble tellement
plein de bon sens que vous nous dites
quand vous l'expliquer aux pouvoirs
publics
concrètement vous réponds quoi
concrètement aujourd'hui dans ce pays
comme dans beaucoup de pays dans le
monde
je je je porte pas la critique sur le
nom du gouvernement je dis simplement
que la santé n'a pas de prix
est ce que nous l'ont craint c'est
d'être d'être stigmatisés et que bien au
delà de la crise sanitaire
il reste quelque chose de ce doigt
pointé sur nos métiers de service qu'ils
s'agissent de traiteur d'hôtellerie de
restauration on a pendant toute cette
année dit c'est dangereux
un de façon subliminale 1 on a fait
comprendre aux anneaux consommateurs
c'était dangereux de fréquenter nos
établissements et je pense que le plan
de relance qui va nous être proposées il
doit être absolument ciblées sur nos
professions et il doit être concentrée
sur les grandes métropoles parce que je
vous rappelle que les grandes métropoles
françaises leur envoyer mes confrères
lyonnais mais on pourrait parler de
cannes sur tout paris que je représente
paris est une ville monde 1 100
touristes paris regardez aujourd'hui
votre confrère des échos qui est quand
même parmi le journal le plus sérieux
sur le plan économique il annonce sa
disparition de 50 % des restaurants le
journal les échos il parle de 90000
restaurants qui vont disparaître
il faut quand même mesurer l'impact
économique mais aussi l'impact social
derrière que ce confinement va produire
j'ai seulement la disparition d'un
restaurant sur deux vous vous
l'expliquez comment les aides ne sont
pas ça c'est pas parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé de cet accompagnement mais dans le
concret ça ne se passe pas aussi
facilement ou c'est un dispositif qui a
été peut-être mal évalué tout simplement
mais je pense que quand on a fait nos
demandes le dispositif était très bien
calibrée lors du premier confinement
mais personne n'a imaginé que cette
crise allait durer aussi longtemps
là on envisage maintenant qu'on va aller
jusque plus d'un an de crise sanitaire
dont d'empêchement de travail et de les
pancartes que vous venez de voir ces
laissez nous travailler on est plutôt on
n'est pas habitué on va faire des
demandes des dons on est habitué à se
lever le matin et travailler dans nos
professions
aujourd'hui pour pas rentrer dans un
débat technique on est à la merci de nos
bailleurs parce qu'à aucune loi qui peut
imposer un propriétaire de restaurant
d'hôtel à abandonner une partie du loyer
il ya une incitation fiscale mais qui
n'a pas force de loi et le bailleur en
face de nous il peut dire moi je veux
pas le savoir vous me payer mon loyer
vous n'ayez pas pu travailler c'est pas
mon problème
on est face à ce problème là qu'est un
problème immense parce que 70 % des
frais qui continue à courir quand nous
n'avons pas la possibilité de travailler
sont constitués par les loyers est le
deuxième sujet on a des centaines de
milliers de collaborateurs qu'on n'a pas
pu faire venir au travail parce que nous
étions soit fermées soit on avait des
jauges qui nous limite est dans vos
activités
ils ont accumulé des droits aux congés
payés c'est le droit du travail et ses
droits aux congés payés constitue une
véritable bombe à retardement qui va
falloir honoré et financièrement au
printemps et à l'été prochain et les
entreprises qui auront plus passer la
première étape du bailleur se trouveront
condamné par la seconde étape économique
est en cessation de paiement quand il va
falloir décaissé ses congés payés et on
est une industrie de main d'oeuvre comme
le bâtiment donc chez nous les salaires
représentent souvent 40 à 50 % de notre
activité faut mesurer quand même si une
charge énorme les pouvoirs publics en
ont pris conscience mais n'ont pas de
solution à nous proposer à ce jour
comment vous avez vécu l'antre-2
confinement si j'ose dire à ce que
clairement les clientes sont revenus non
dans les restaurants il y avait une
envie qui c'est qui s'est matérialisé
qui s'est concrétisée de façons très
différentes suivant que vous étiez dans
une zone touristique une zone de
villégiature à la campagne en bord de
mer à la montagne ça s'est plutôt bien
passé et mes confrères qui ont travaillé
je en juillet-août ont pu retrouver une
activité normale voire supérieur à
l'accoutumée par contre dans les grandes
métropoles dans les grandes villes paris
lyon et lille
beaucoup de villes de métropole
il faut les appeler comme ça notamment
celles qui sont tournées internationales
n'ont pas repris du tout une activité
normale
a paris nous sommes restés à 50% de
baisse en moyenne dans les restaurants
et à 80 % de baisse et chez des
traiteurs jusqu'à 100 % d'activité qui
ont disparu donc ya pas eu vraiment de
reprise dans les grandes métropoles
c'est pour ça que ce second confinement
avec son couvre-feu du 16 octobre et ces
fermetures du 30 octobre
on les a vécues dans les grandes villes
comme un coup de grâce
parce que on sait très bien que dans les
grandes villes ce sera beaucoup plus
compliqué de repartir alors il ya encore
pire chez vous si vous passez cette
expression ce sont les discothèques 1
qui n'ont jamais pu rouvrir ce que vous
avez des nouvelles vous communiquez avec
entre guillemets ses collègues
deux boîtes de nuit elles ont disparu
aujourd'hui ses discothèques en france
carreman qui l ont bénéficié d'un
dispositif qui leur a permis pour
beaucoup d'entre elles d'honorer ses
charges de loyer donc certaines sont en
sommeil certaines ne rouvriront pas
aujourd'hui il est clair que la durée de
cette crise
si si c'est pas sur le plan économique
c'est sur le plan moral que les chefs
d'entreprise ne vont pas pouvoir
reprendre
on leur a coupé l'herbe sous le pied on
leur a coupé toute envie de se battre
pour payer les dettes qu'ils ont
accumulés parce qu'il faut bien mesurer
que ces entreprises qui elles repartent
demain c'est avec un fardeau énorme de
dettes qu'elles ont accumulés par un
nunchuk mesures hâtives chefs
d'entreprise ne veulent pas se voir cinq
années à la merci des banques et et à
travailler juste pour honorer des dettes
il faut bien mesurer qu'il y a une
dimension économique mais une dimension
également psychologique à cette crise
merci à vous a pas ce qu'annonçait
d'avoir été avec nous restaurateurs
président du génie paris ile de france
qui représente donc les indépendants de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration merci
à vous et cette information
internationale laser metge ont abattu
par erreur un hélicoptère militaire
russe au dessus de l'arménie l'appareil
escorter un convoi de la 102e base
militaire rudement d'équipage ont été
tués un troisième blessé dans un
communiqué la partie serbe neiges
je suis présente ses excuses à la partie
russe à la suite de cet incident
tragique qui relève de l'accident fin de
citation elle reconnaît avoir ouvert le
feu craignant des provocations de la
partie arménienne au conflit du haut
karabakh et qui évoque une mauvaise
visibilité également fait le point avec
notre correspondant à moscou antoine
claireaux on commence à en savoir
davantage sur les circonstances de cet
incident
en effet il ya un communiqué
l'azerbaïdjan a reconnu avoir abattu
l'hélicoptère russe s'est excusé pour
rappel hélicoptère en question
escortaient un convoi la 102e base
militaire russe sur le territoire de
l'arménie dans une zone frontalière de
l'azerbaïdjan quand il a été touché par
un missile sol-air le pilote a ensuite
perdu le contrôle de l'appareil et s'est
écrasé dans une zone montagneuse
toujours en armes et le bilan humain est
de deux morts et un blessé
tous trois membres de l'équipage un
porte-parole du ministère de la défense
russe a d'ailleurs confirmé que
l'hélicoptère avait été abattu en dehors
de toute zone de combat et cela pourrait
être lourd de conséquences les fuit
depuis le début des hostilités
la russie a promis de venir en aide à
l'arménie si les combats venait à
s'étendre sur le territoire arménien en
vertu du traité de sécurité collective
qui unit les deux pays
il faudra donc maintenant guetter la
réaction de la russie
cet incident rappelle au passage celui
de 2015
quand un avion de combat russes a été
abattu par les chasseurs turcs au dessus
de la frontière turco syrienne al ahly
suscité des tensions entre moscou et
ankara
mais sans que cela ne les empêche de
coopérer sur le dossier syrien
encore jusqu'aujourd'hui
fraîchement élu à la tête de la bolivie
le nouveau président luis arce est entré
en fonction ce dimanche mi novembre et
au lendemain de son investiture c'est
son mentor et ancien chef d'état evo
morales qui est arrivé en bolivie un an
après son exil forcé retour sur cette
année mouvementée avec quentin mots
clairs nous nous sommes sentis orphelins
sans père mais maintenant notre père
revient est must au pad
douze mois après son départ précipité
evo morales rentrer au pays l'ancien
président a atterri à l'aéroport
argentin de jujuy avant de parcourir
plus de mille kilomètres dans un van
afin d'atteindre la frontière puis de
traverser à pied le pont qui relie la
ville argentine de kiaka à celle de vie
la zone en bolivie un retour d'exil
triomphant pour l'homme politique
il y a un an après une victoire
contestée à l'élection présidentielle
evo morales est poussé à la démission
par l'armée l'opposition il part pour le
mexique et dénonce un coup d'état
l'organisation des états américains a
pris une décision politique ni technique
ni juridique
le seul moyen d'arrêter la crise et un
dialogue national des paysanneries des
organisations internationales peuvent y
participer
je tiens à dire aux nations unies
n'acceptez pas ce genre de coup d'état
le pays connaît alors une période
d'instabilité dans les rues de la paz
des violences éclatent et plusieurs
dizaines de personnes décèdent lors
d'affrontements entre manifestants
rivaux et dans des heurts avec les
forces de l'ordre
après un court séjour à cuba pour des
raisons médicales morales poursuit son
exil en argentine le 18 décembre 2019
le procureur général de bolivie ordonne
un mandat d'arrêt international contre
l'ancien chef d'état accusé par le
gouvernement auto-proclamé de jeanine
agnès d'inciter ses partisans à se
révolter
il fait l'objet d'une enquête pour
sédition et terrorisme
le président déchu rejette ces
accusations auront bon entendement evo
morales est toujours président donc ce
procès avec mandat d'arrêt est injuste
anticonstitutionnelles et illégales
illégal à distance evo morales mène son
parti le mouvement vers le socialisme en
vue du prochain scrutin présidentiel
nommé directeur de campagne il annonce
le 19 janvier que son ancien ministre de
l'économie de luis arce et sera le
candidat de sa formation politique
parallèlement il dépose sa candidature
pour briguer un siège au sénat
candidature invalidée au motif qu evo
morales ne réside pas en bolivie après
plusieurs reports liés à la pandémie de
kobe 19 luis arce et remporte finalement
la présidentielle le 18 octobre dernier
malgré la victoire du candidat
socialiste dès le premier tour du
scrutin l'opposition continue de
manifester évoque des fraudes
c'est très facile de se rendre compte de
ce qui va se passer il n'y a pas
d'argent en bolivie luis arce et nous
endetter pour un montant de plus ou
moins de 1000 $ pour chaque bolivien
c'est comme ça que nous sommes endettés
à bidon fraude
il y a eu une fraude ils ont fait croire
aux boliviens que le mas avait gagné en
raison du partage du vote entre santa
cruz est la base c'est un mensonge
le mas a perdu mais comme ils disposent
de tout l'appareil de la cour électorale
qui le valide
ils veulent le faire croire à la bolivie
et au monde
de retour sur ses terres evo morales ne
risque plus rien vis-à-vis de la justice
celle ci a levé le mandat d'arrêt contre
lui huit jours après la victoire de luis
arce et reste à voir quelle place
occupera désormais l'ancien chef d'état
auprès du nouveau président et pour en
parler de ce retour nous sommes avec
maurice lemoine journaliste spécialiste
de l'amérique latine bonsoir maurice
lemoine merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france est-ce que ça sonne un
petit peu ce retour comme une revanche
or evo morales ce que c'est qu'une
revanche j'utiliserai peut-être
peut-être pas ce mot mais c'est en tout
cas un retour de la de la démocratie en
bolivie puisqu'on a vu pendant un an un
gouvernement illégitime c'est eux
on en parlait dans votre reportage il ya
eu effectivement un coup d'état de
bêtises 9 et vous morales avait gagné
l'élection
ce sont sa victoire avait été remise en
cause par l'organisation des états
américains de relance mais elle a été
depuis démentie par un certain nombre de
chercheurs indépendants et donc
effectivement la victoire d'avoir c'est
d'une manière assez paradoxale tailleur
ou intéressante il ya un choc là des
événements le retour du mouvement vers
le socialisme en bolivie correspond
coïncide avec ce qui se passe
actuellement aux etats-unis où le
président de l'ast rhône peu est en
grande difficulté c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
il ya là tout terrain tout un symbole
puisque les états unis avaient appuyé le
coup d'état contre hugo morales seront
tour à des morales en bolivie est ce que
ça met fin aux accusations de fraude
électorale à son encontre
bah écoute et oui le sous-sol de
l'actuel président ochoa s'est bien
évidemment conteste tout à fait cette
cette accusation de fraude électorale
les potes par ailleurs la dernière
élection où il a gagné avec 55% des voix
toute équivoque sur le fait que le
mouvement vers le socialisme mas est
majoritaire dans le temps dans le pays
elle a ouvert le phénomène reportage qui
est tout à fait similaire à ce qui se
passe aux etats unis c'est à dire que le
l'extrême droite la plus radicale
conteste le résultat d'élections domaine
que donald trump aux états unis
est en train de créer une situation
absolument vakaba acadabrantesque comme
aurait dit à deux anciens présidents
alors que manifestement il a perdu
aujourd'hui clairement evo morales dit
qu'il veut arrêter la politique il veut
se lancer dans le militantisme syndical
même faire de la pisciculture est ce
qu'on peut y croire selon vous alors il
va pas et bien évidemment il ne va pas
arrêter la politique simplement il ya un
des bras et il a une proposition en
indiquant très clairement que le
président élu de la bolivie ça n'est
plus evo morales c'est luis arce et un
don qu'il ne pas faire de l'ombre à son
successeur cela étant depuis sa sa
province à province de chino les ducs
apparaît il va bien aller bien
évidemment avoir un rôle politique
puisqu'il demeure président du mouvement
vers le socialisme mas le parti qui est
actuellement au pouvoir et que il
compris dans le nouvel comme nouveau
gouvernement où les nouvelles
institutions on va par exemple que le
nouveau président du sénat est un très
jeune en droit diko au relief qui est un
projet clairement aujourd'hui lui
sarcelles va-t-il pouvoir s'affranchir
s'émanciper de son mentor je pense
qu'ils veulent faire de sûr on a on est
dans ce genre de situation dans une
oscillation qu'on connaît partout c'est
à dire que le dauphin doit être très
clairement indiqué qu à partir de deux
doses aujourd'hui c'est lui le président
dans le registre lui c'est lui moi c'est
moi mais par ailleurs evo morales n'a
pas l'intention de faire de l'ombre à
celui qu'on appelle son dauphin qui a
été son ministre des colonies pendant
pendant une dizaine d'années et qui a
été appelé le leu leu leu l'artisan du
miracle bolivien est donc en principe la
fois il ya même pas en principe il ya
aucune difficulté dans ce sens vous
pariez par deux fois vous avez fait
allusion à cette élection américaine est
ce que ça peut changer quelque chose
justement sur la situation politique en
bolivie et notamment pesé sur d'une
manière ou d'une autre
evo morales abbas a changé certaines
choses en amérique latine il ya un
symbole éclatant c'est que le le
ministre des affaires étrangères du
venezuela avec qui la présidente dé
facto avait aucune relation le mille
saveurs étrangères est venu donc à
l'intronisation de luis archer et il a
repris possession de l'ambassade du
venezuela en bolivie en enlevant le
portrait du président autoproclamé roi
noyau et c'est vrai que dans les dents
les équilibres géopolitiques latino
américains on a à la modification du pos
du panorama puisque on a souvent parlé
d'un d'une fin de cycle en amérique
latine en considérant que la gauche
était en train de s'effondrer
or on a vu la gauche ou de centre gauche
revenir en argentine revenir au mexique
le venezuela résiste la bolivie
maintenant revient à gauche
peut-être demain en 2021 l'équateur
passera-t-il lui aussi à ouga la gauche
au centre à gauche et est donc
effectivement face aux états unis on a
là une remontée en puissance de la
gauche latino américaine avec peut-être
très très prochainement à la remise en
action de l'union des nations sud
américaines qui avaient été qui a été
détruite par les gouvernements
conservateurs de mauricio macri en
argentine ball sonar au brésil ball
sonar ou d'ailleurs qui se retrouve très
isolée maintenant avec la perte à la
fois 2
jeannie les andes en bolivie mais
surtout celle de donald trump aux états
unis le retour de morales sur le sale
bolivien est perçu comme ans dans son
ensemble on a vu quelques scènes de joie
mais surtout le pays
ça donne quoi ah bah écoutez c'est une
manière très très classique il ya
évidemment ça va provoquer
l'enthousiasmé de ceux qui pendant 14
ans grâce à sa présidence ont vu leur
situation s'améliorer et sava enragé
ceux qui ont organisé le coup d'état
l'an dernier et qui voit revenir celui
qui a été leur leurs commandes hier le
la de la bête au ni celle qu'il fallait
chasser
merci à vous maurice lemoine journaliste
spécialiste de l'amérique latine d'avoir
été avec nous pour vous exprimer sur ce
retour au pays d'evo morales merci à
vous dans quelques instants rester avec
nous nous partirons aux états unis si
certains chefs d'état notamment
européens félicite joe biden que les
médias américains ont donné gagnant la
chine et la russie préférait attendre
les résultats officiels avant toute
déclaration
et puis nous parlerons uvre excite les
négociations reprennent aujourd'hui avec
londres à une
nouvelle donne pour boris johnson la
victoire du démocrate joe biden
justement
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mini
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire rasé à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident
c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde sur les
pentes appartement en énerver grenelle
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
ma journée à mâcon il passe un tour deux
tracts avec nos campagnes il faut savoir
c'est qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles mas pourrait aider un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
là elle en soir vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ai des gandhi il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas là j'oublie
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
21h30 heure française merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france
l'annnonce de la victoire de joe biden
est le fruit des projections des grands
médias américains si cela est de l'ordre
du détail pour certains c'est aussi
l'une des raisons qui poussent certains
électeurs et certains dirigeants rester
prudent sur l'issue de ce vote nous
retrouvons notre reporter thomas bonnet
en direct depuis washington bonsoir
thomas justement comment réagit-on du
côté des américains et en particulier
des républicains ces derniers
développements c'est dans des aspects
les plus contestés par les partisans de
donald trump le fait que ce soit la
presse qui est annoncé la victoire de
joe biden samedi midi si des milliers de
personnes se sont rassemblées dans
l'ensemble du pays c'est parce que des
médias telles que cnn ou encore associé
ty presse ont annoncé la victoire de joe
biden il se base à ce moment là sur le
décompte dans l'état de pennsylvanie où
ils estiment selon leurs projections que
le candidat démocrate a suffisamment
d'avancé pour ne plus être en mesure
d'être rattrapé par donald trump mais
pour les partisans du locataire de la
maison blanche cela pose plusieurs
questions d'abord est ce que le résultat
doit être considéré comme officiel alors
que seuls les médias on est avancée pour
le moment cette victoire de joe biden
surtout que ces médias en question on a
souvent parlé ici ont dans leur grande
majorité fait campagne contre donald
trump sont-ils dès lors les plus
légitimes pour jouer les arbitres et ce
alors que le décompte se poursuit dans
un certain nombre d'états et alors que
les recours ont été déposés par l'équipe
juridique de donald trump écouter ce
qu'en pense le principal intéressé
donald trump comme souvent ça se passe
sur twitter
depuis quand les minables médias de
masse des sites qui sera notre prochain
président nous avons tous beaucoup
appris au cours des deux dernières
semaines
alors il faut quand même reconnaître que
des médias tels que fox news le new york
post plutôt acquis à la cause du
président sortant ont également annoncé
la victoire de joe biden mais cette
situation n'est pas sans rappeler celle
qui s'est déroulée en l'an 2000 lors de
l'élection qui opposait georges double
bush à al gore à l'époque un recours
dans l'état de floride avait nécessité
un recomptage des voix dans l'état il
avait fallu attendre alors 36 jours pour
connaître le vainqueur de l'élection
thomas malgré le fait que ces résultats
ne soient pas officiel ça n'a pas
empêché des leaders internationaux de
dresser assez tôt leurs félicitations à
l'ancien vice président oui certains
dirigeants notamment en europe ont déjà
adressé leurs félicitations c'est le cas
par exemple des manuels macron dengue et
la merkel ou encore de boris johnson
même chose pour le premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou d'autres
dirigeants ont décidé d'être plus
prudents et de patienter jusqu'à
l'annoncé des résultats officiels c'est
le cas notamment de la chine et de la
russie qui préfèrent ne pas se
précipiter pour commenter des résultats
qui sont contestés par le président
sortant lui même
idem du côté du chef de l'état mexicain
qui dit vouloir attendre que toutes les
questions légales soient résolus avant
de ne pas faire preuve d'imprudence
justement concernant cette élection
merci thomas abonnés en direct de
washington alors joe biden ne critique
pas victoire trop vite si donald trump
n'a pas encore présenté à d'éléments de
preuve d'éventuelles fraudes le scrutin
est il pour autant déjà terminée c'est
l'objet justement de notre face à face
ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec théo lobry démocrate
animateurs du groupe bernie sanders
france bonsoir vous théo d'aubry merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés nicolas
conc'air monde et républicaine sauveur 6
france
merci à vous et nicolas conc'air d'être
avec nous également lors y avait déjà
pas mal de tension avant mais alors là
ça chauffe encore plus entre donald
trump et les médias américains qu'il
accuse tout de même de lui avoir volé sa
victoire est ce que c'est un petit peu
voilà tout match pour reprendre voilà
une expression américaine de ceux
déclarés volés cette élection nicholas
cronk heures c'est pas un peu trop quand
même
alors déjà il ya important de rappeler
quand on est dans un système
constitutionnel aux états unis que cette
constitution à date de 1791 et c'est
bien elle qui tapinent les rênes à
l'article si vous l'avez vous dire de
deux sections 3 paragraphe 1 qui va dire
que donc c'est au vote et qui va
déterminer l'issue du scrutin ont déjà
il est nécessaire de le voir aller
jusqu'au bout du dépouillement et que
l'issue l'officialisation la
certification de ces résultats ne sera
donnée que par les grands électeurs
la réunion des grands électeurs
il n'y a aucun moment indiqué que c'est
à cnn de prononcer qui est le résultat
qui est résultat acquis et le vainqueur
de ce scrutin pour moi on assiste
vraiment à une espèce de coup de force
quand même un coup d'état avertit
nicolas singer alors c'est vrai que
c'est pas que cnn qui a annoncé ses
résultats c'est souvent voilà le fruit
de la société de presse
c'est cette tradition aux états unis fox
news a quand même suivi
on a un peu perdu nicolas scamps caire
on va aller se frotter aux lobry t on
oublie tout de même vous comprenez
qu'elle ça fasse un petit peu désordre
parce que c'est vrai qu'on rappelle
lorsque nous a rappelé poteau m'abonner
avant 2000 il a fallu attendre le
recomptage total des voix contestées par
al gore et de george bush pour avoir le
le vrai vainqueur les résultats
officiels est ce qu'on n'a pas un petit
peu pardonnez moi l'expression sackey
donald trump parce que tout simplement
on ne l'aimé pas beaucoup dans les
médias américains
non pas du tout je crois pas enfin la
situation entre 2000 et 2020 elle n'est
pas du tout comparable déjà rien que par
le fait qu'en 2000 c'est plutôt la
floride avec quelques centaines de voix
qui pose problème
là on a quand même 4 aux états qui sont
à plus de entre 10 et 40 mille de voie
de plus pour joe biden enfin un trucage
ou annoncé trop tôt les résultats c'est
simplement mensonger de dire ça de la
part des républicains du président on
aurait pu le dire dans le cas des aides
de 2000 forcément puisque c'était entre
200 et 1000 voix qui séparait dans un
seul état là on a le 4 et à avec plus de
10000 cac 40 mille voix d'écart pour joe
biden il faut arrêter la plaisanterie en
donald trump s'est pas offusqué du fait
que soit cnn fox news et la suisse y est
plus qu il le déclare vainqueur alors il
faudrait peut-être pas abuser non plus
or en 2000 barak entend tout et
n'importe quoi nicolas square guerre je
sais pas si vous avez eu le temps de
tout écouter vous étiez en train de
bourrer installé c'est vrai que voilà
votre contradicteur théo lobry nous
disait que c'était pas vraiment le même
cas qu'en 2000 c'est vrai que là il ya
une plusieurs milliers le dizaines de
milliers de voix d'écart dans plusieurs
états différents est-ce que donald trump
ne fait pas un petit peu mauvais perdant
sur ce coup là on pourra peut-être en
2000 face à al gore les bouches il y
avait une annonce prématurée par cnn qui
avaient tous afficher au grand écran
pour la primaire de l'annonce que gore
avait remporté l'élection
l'histoire nous a montré que ce n'était
pas tout à fait le cas c'est allé deux
fois la cour suprême il des recours
juridiques qui ont abouti et qui a
tranché en faveur de bush vingt ans plus
tard nous voilà maintenant dans une
situation où il ya des cas très
spécifique dans chacun des états der
compte qu'ils vont se faire parce qu'on
est dans une marge d'erreur vraiment
très ténue au whisky unseen en chine en
géorgie et d'autres cas de soupçons de
fraude qui vont être
tu es au niveau des tribunaux des cours
fédérales ou à la cour suprême si
nécessaire
je rappelle que la dendre des d'état qui
est très scrutées qui à la pennsylvanie
il ya une modification du code électoral
de manière unilatérale
trois jours avant l'élection pour
faciliter le vote par correspondance
avec des conditions qui sont au taquet
anticonstitutionnelle donc la laque ou
la cour suprême va s'en saisir et il va
y avoir tout un process juridique qui
est menée par de nombreux avocats
théo lobry vous êtes inquiet justement
par un une éventuelle saisie de la cour
suprême on rappelle que donald trump a
nommé voilà un tiers de cette cour
suprême a renouvelé ça fait six juges
conservateurs sur sur neuf est ce que ça
peut porter à conséquence sur cette
élection selon vous non parce que ça
n'arrivera jamais que la cour suprême
des juges ce qui est en train de se
passer au niveau du vote pour la simple
et bonne raison que la cour suprême ne
voudra pas être plongé dans la chute de
donald trump et qu'elle a une vocation à
être supérieures aux intérêts personnels
de tel ou tel candidat à la cour suprême
si jamais et ce qui n'arrivera pas
déjugé le vote est allé en faveur de
donaldson
c'est ce qu'on appellera un coup d'état
nicolas conc'air justement cette cour
suprême vous vous avez la même analyse
que côté all aubry où je vais absolument
immonde et dans ce sens car on dise
abondé dans le sens en disant que c'est
la plus haute juridiction aux états unis
la cour suprême est la plus votre
confiance auprès des citoyens américains
d'où le fait que goldman est maintenu
dans son état actuel de neuf juges
contrairement à des volontés des
démocrates qui joue pas forcément cartes
sur table dans le fait qu'il pourrait un
peu saturé les cours comme on dit donc
augmenter le nombre là n'est pas la
question
tout ça pour dire que quand bien même il
ya des juges qui ont été nommés dans le
droit par donald trump président en
exercice jusqu'au 21 janvier prochain à
minima ils essaient ses juges l'aï zobi
cela de droit constitutionnel il
respecte les institutions n'ya pas c'est
pas une cour partisane maintenant ils
vont apprécier l'ensemble de ces
éléments à la lueur du droit et donc du
coup il ya déjà des recours qui ont été
faits sur la tête il
l'ensemble des bulletins qui sont
arrivés après la fin du scrutin ont été
mis de côté donc ces longs sont
comptabilisés de manière distincte de
manière à ce que lorsqu'il y aura un
jugement qui sera il sera arrêté
on pourra savoir si ces bulletins sont
ou légaux ou frauduleux et doivent ne
pas être comptabilisée en tout cas les
républicains eux clairement affirme
aujourd'hui qu'il y à des fraudes et
irrégularités des bottes de logiciels
des bulletins comptés après la date
butoir ou encore des morts qui votent
théo lobry ces accusations pour moi
devons fonds ont ricané tout simplement
vous les exclus et totalement non mais
alors qu'il ya un petit peu de fraude ça
arrive en fait à tous les scrutins
toutes les études qui sont sérieuses à
ce sujet qui ont été menées au cours des
différentes dernières élections des
dernières décennies elles mesurent la
fraude à moins de 0 1% donc en fait
c'est absolument rien alors il ya
quelques vidéos qui circulent sur
youtube dont on ne sait absolument pas
la provenance on ne sait pas l'année
elles sont parfois trafic et puisque l
on était ce qu'on appelle des bouquets
c'est à dire qu'elles ont été vérifiés
et on a conclu à ce que c'était de cette
news donc ça en fait ça c'est pas une
preuve
et puis admettons que ces vins vidéo qui
traînent sur youtube soit une preuve ça
représente quoi peut-être 200 500
bulletins de vote
on est à plus de 40 milles en
pennsylvanie si je dis pas de bêtises et
on est à plus de 10000 en géorgie dont
qui sont des états qui sont qui peut
serrer qui sont les derniers à avoir
donné
le le job de nantes est entre guillemets
donc il faut arrêter un petit peu et
tout ça que les états unis ce n'est pas
un pays du tiers-monde eux sans manquer
de respect au tiers-monde
c'est un pays la première puissance
mondiale et qui est capable de mener à
bien une élection faut arrêter la
plaisanterie alors là la question parce
qu'il ya eu quelque chose d'inédit dans
cette élection qui vous avez n'ont pas
échappé plus de 90 millions de votes par
correspondance on sait que ces votes
peuvent susciter la fronde et que c'est
vrai que les états unis toute puissance
qui sont n'était pas forcément préparés
à autant de votes par correspondance
nicolas conc'air vous vous êtes
justement particulièrement inquiets sont
ces votes par correspondance puisque
c'était le leitmotiv de trump 1 que
selon lui elle favoriserait les fraudes
mais silva il l'a dit bien avant
l'élection pour un dessin niveau de la
france il est important de rappeler que
le vote par correspondance a été arrêté
par un arrêt depuis 1975 la récente de
centristes de poniatowski donc justement
parce qu'il y avait des soupçons de du
baladeur harvesting comme on appelait ça
aux états unis qui consiste à faire
utiliser un peu la faiblesse de certains
tiers pour aller voter en leur nom il ya
effectivement beaucoup de suspicion et
de malversations liées à ce canal là en
revanche pour ce qui va être de
l'intégrité des élections ça vous tient
peut-être pas à coeur vous mais moi en
tant qu'américain républicain je suis
absolument mais confiant et attaché à
ses institutions démocratiques et que
toute fraude quel que soit le nom la
quantité nécessite d'être investiguer
jugé c'est un crime fédéral aux états
unis.le peut-être à vos yeux se salit
rien pour moi c'est très important on
encourt cinq ans de prison dix mille
euros d'amendé
c'est très très significatif et s'il est
en confiance dans ça vous laisseriez
aisément refaire le compte de chacun de
ces bulletins juste pour garantir la
fiabilité l'intégrité de ces élections
il en va être de la légimité c'était de
cette élection et du mandat des quatre
années à venir était au louvre il est la
réponse aura pas de souci on veut ils
peuvent recompter autant qu'ils veulent
de toute façon les écarts sont trop cons
dont on ne
on ne basculera pas de plus 48 les plus
50000 parfois à moins 10 milles entre
guillemets au pire à la marge on va
retrouver peut-être 200 bulletins ou 300
bulletins de plus pour trump ou 200
bulletins de 300 buts un de plus pour
joe biden pour ce qui est par contre
effectivement des fraudes qui sont à la
marge qui sont absolument qu'ils ne
représentent absolument rien sur les
chaînes des 150 millions de personnes
qui ont voté
effectivement faut investiguer punir les
coupables c'est un crime fédéral comme
ça a été très bien rappelé par
l'intervenant républicains voient là
mais c'est comme dans toute élection en
france aussi des investigations quand il
ya une fraude électorale et jusqu'à
présent on n'a jamais on n'a jamais eu
de soucis ou 2 ou de problèmes parce
qu'en fait les candidats en confiance et
les candidats même quand ils sont dans
une position où c'est serré c'était le
cas aux états unis
les périodes précédentes comme al gore
en 2000
en fait concède la fin accepte la
défaite et et font passer l'intérêt de
la nation au dessus de leurs intérêts
personnels et on voit bien qu est ce que
fait donald trump c'est d'essayer d'en
céder tout le monde dans sa chute
sauf que ça s'arrêtera très vite puisque
la cour suprême malgré le fait qu'elle
soit à majorité conservatrice ne ne se
permettra pas de tomber dans le même
trop que donald trump et il faudrait
mieux d'ailleurs que donald trump
s'arrête là accepte sa défaite et à la
rigueur qui retente le coup en 2024 à
nicolas ce con car justement c'est
intéressant ce que maudit à théo lobry
ce sera le mot de la fin sur la
stratégie de donald trump c'est vrai que
là on le voit voilà poster des tweets
ans il renomme des membres de son
gouvernement comme finalement si ça
allait continuer s'il était repartir
pour un tour si j'ose dire ce que c'est
c'est la bonne stratégie ne faudrait pas
quitter la table et peut-être comme le
dit théo lobry revenir tout simplement
dans quatre ans c'est très intéressant
et très symptomatique d'un partisan de
bernie sanders qui lui s'est retiré à
plusieurs reprises lors des primaires
démocrates justement pour laisser passer
qui s'est fait gauler justement les
primaires démocrates
justement parce qu'il y avait des
affaires un peu
l'establishment a été privilégié donc on
leur a volé sa campagne donc très bon
perdant deux fois de suite c'est
honorable ça vous honore mais bon en
termes de combativité donald trump sera
là et jusqu'au bout et tous les recours
juridiques qu'il a à sa disposition
si deuxième mandat il n'ya pas il y aura
toujours un boulevard peut-être 2024 il
aura à peine l'âge de joe biden
aujourd'hui mais il ya également un
grand chantier qui est pour assurer la
liberté d'expression aux états unis on
voit bien cet acharnement médiatique
dont il a été victime depuis le début de
son mandat ou ilan et ses cdd liban des
insultes et lui sa famille son électorat
et quand on voit la mobilisation malgré
tout ça avec tout ce qu'on a pu dire sur
trump 70 millions personnes qui se
dépassent pour glisser un bulletin c'est
absolument faramineux et il ya forcément
donc un boulevard à saisir pour recréer
un espace de liberté pour sortir un peu
de ces géants de la tech qui ont une
position monopolistique de la silicon
valley et et recrée donc des nouveaux
réseaux donc on voit aussi bien sur la
chaîne de télévision haut à network par
l'air qui commence à monter en
popularité et qui vont vraiment
permettre de contrecarrer toutes ces
censures tout ce shadow ban
tout ce qu'à une seule culture qui peut
exister sur les réseaux tôt milan que je
ne citerai pas notre cas je pense que
c'est vraiment une belle belle
aspirations merci on est presque au
caire et à théo lobry d'avoir été avec
nous et outre-manche les négociations
commerciales reprennent aujourd'hui
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne le 31 décembre signera la fin
de la période de transition qui a suivi
la sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne
idéalement les deux parties doivent
trouver un accord avant la mi-novembre
qu'il puisse être votée au parlement au
parlement européen
mais les points de divergence persistent
le royaume uni qui pouvait aussi compter
justement sur son alliance avec donald
trump risque de se trouver isolées avec
l'arrivée de joe biden ce dernier a
toujours considéré le break sites comme
une erreur estelle farges
il ne reste plus qu'à le faire ce sont
les mots de boris johnson sur les
chances de parvenir à un accord post
break site entre londres et bruxelles
après s'être entretenu avec la
présidente de la commission européenne
ce week end le premier ministre
britannique se montre optimiste pourtant
les points de désaccord sont bel et bien
toujours là et ce sont toujours les
mêmes
il y
la pêche sur ce dossier l'union
européenne souhaitent pouvoir accéder
librement aux eaux britanniques riche en
poissons alors que le royaume-uni
désirant contrôler l'accès et puis il ya
les garanties exigées par l'union
européenne sur la concurrence
le eux souhaitent s'assurer que le
royaume uni respecte par exemple les
mêmes normes que bruxelles en matière de
droit du travail ou d'environnement afin
de protéger le marché européen et ses
entreprises avec boris johnson le
premier ministre britannique
nous avons fait un état des lieux des
négociations quelques avancées ont été
faites mais de grandes divergences
subsistent notamment sur la pêche et les
garanties d'équité nos équipes
continueront de travailler
d'arrache-pied la semaine prochaine et
nous resterons en étroite communication
dans les prochains jours car le temps
pour trouver un terrain d'entente est
compté la mi novembre avait été fixé
comme date limite pour conclure un
accord qui puisse être adoptée par le
parlement européen avant le 1er janvier
c'est à cette date que le royaume
devrait se détacher des normes de lieu
en l'absence d'avancées concrètes c'est
la menace d'un odile qui revient frapper
à la porte des deux parties malgré les
efforts de lieu pour trouver des
solutions de sérieuses divergences
subsistent sur les garanties d'équité de
gouvernance et de pêche
ce sont des conditions essentielles à
tout partenariat économique
l'ue est prête à tous les scénarios sans
compter que la récente élection de joe
biden mais un peu plus la pression sur
les britanniques
boris johnson a beaucoup misé sur sa
relation avec donald trump pour espérer
obtenir un accord commercial avec les
états unis
quant à trump on se souvient tous des
éloges adressés à son homologue
britannique homologues qui qualifiait de
type bien c'est donc une opération
séduction que boris johnson a lancé sur
les réseaux sociaux le 7 novembre date à
laquelle le monde entier et n'arrive
élections de joe biden le britannique a
été l'un des premiers à féliciter le
démocrate
félicitations à joe biden pour son
élection en tant que président des états
unis et à kamala harris pour cette
victoire historique
les etats unis sont nos alliés les plus
importants et j'ai hâte de coopérer
étroitement sur nos priorités communes
du changement climatique au commerce et
à la défense les relations entre boris
johnson et joe biden ne sont pas
vraiment au beau fixe
lors de la campagne pour le bric c'est
joe biden
n'avait pas hésité à qualifier beau joe
de je cite clown physiques et
émotionnels de donald trump
pas sûr donc que cette offensive de
charme parviennent à porter ses fruits
et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alors cette élection de joe biden est ce
qu'elles peuvent vraiment changer la
donne pour boris johnson oui
probablement élevé pour deux raisons la
première raison c'est que lorsque le
président élu s'installera à la maison
blanche
il y aura une sorte de changement de
logiciel puisque donald trump étaient
propres excite au boris johnson et qui
lui avait promis à un accord de libre
échange sur mesure avec les états unis
d'ailleurs ce qu'il n'a pas fait puisque
les anglais ont constaté que les
américains allaient être des partenaires
difficiles là le dante donc avec ce
nouveau logiciel
effectivement cela signifie que les
états unis se montrent plus favorable je
parie donne que votre sujet là a
expliqué était à l'origine le silo wild
side et il considère que en effet
l'union européenne est un élément de
stabilité en europe et d'autre part de
façon un peu plus cynique il considère
que pour les intérêts américains
il était mieux défendu lorsque la
grande-bretagne était dedans qu'avec une
grande bretagne à l'extérieur cela dit
joe biden a montré son attachement à ce
qu'on appelle l'accord du vendredi saint
c'est à dire un accord entre toutes les
parties prenantes et tous les partis
politiques d'irlande du nord et de la
république d'irlande pour mettre une fin
à 30 ans de guerre civile qui a fait
plus de 3500 morts
donc à partir de ce moment là on a
appris des décisions qui pensent les
institutions mais aussi avec l'aide de
l'union européenne et bien la
suppression de toutes frontières
physiques entre l'irlande du nord qui
appartient au royaume uni et la
république d'irlande qui continue de
faire partie
de l'union européenne et donc joe biden
a dit très clairement qu' il ne pouvait
pas concevoir que cet accord soit mis en
difficulté et que lire on court le
risque de voir revenir une frontière ne
serait ce que des paniers entre
l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande
il a été très clair il a même dit que
dans ce cas il n'y aurait pas de
possibilité d'accords de libre échange
entre les états unis et la grande
bretagne alors encore dias et d'autres
facteurs qui poussent le premier
ministre est à nîmes dans un sens ou
dans l'autre
oui alors monsieur boris johnson a
quelques difficultés avec le parlement
de westminster et cette semaine il est
très probable dit on que la chambre dès
lors rejette son projet de loi qui est
ce projet de loi pour garantir à un
marché unique fluide entre la grande
bretagne et l'irlande du nord et ceux ci
qui est le risque grèce ce texte de loi
risqueraient de venir contredire la nex
irlande précisément du traité de sortie
de l'union européenne du traité qui a
été ratifiée à la fin de l'année
dernière tous les anciens premiers
ministres britanniques vivant se sont
d'ailleurs opposés à ce traité et à la
remise en cause de la parole donnée par
le royaume uni le fait d'avoir un accord
de libre échange permettrait
probablement de résoudre assez largement
cette difficulté
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième c'est que la grande bretagne
connaît actuellement une crise
économique très importante du fait de la
pandémie
on prévoit que son pnb rabaissée de 10 %
environ cette année
et donc c'est probablement pas le moment
d'ajouter la crise à la crise et
d'ajouter tous les inconvénients
économiques du la sortie du la sortie de
l'union douanière sens libre échange à
cette crise qui découle de la pandémie
cela dit effectivement boris johnson a
s'est fixé lui-même
une ligne rouge qui est la défense de la
souveraineté du royaume uni il
n'acceptera pas de faire des concessions
sur un sujet qui touche à la
souveraineté
qu'il s'agisse de l'aide aux entreprises
où il s'agisse de la pêche
alors claude blanchemaison évidemment la
question tout le monde se pose quelle
issue un accord ou pas d'accord alors on
a bien vu que ce week-end une sorte de
lueur d'espoir apparaît pour qu'il y ait
un accord
c'est d'ailleurs les mots de de boris
johnson qui dit on voit bien les lignes
se sont qualifiés hier matin il faut
passer à l'acte et c'est un peu aussi ce
que dit ursula von der leyen en étant
plus réaliste en dix ans on a fait des
progrès mais il reste des accords très
importants
alors d'abord je crois qu'on peut dire
que sur les trois points principaux le
premier sur le premier point la sagesse
a prévalu et donc on l'a probablement
trouver un compromis sur la gouvernance
des rapports du régime futur entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni à
savoir que s'il ya les différents et
bien il y aura des tribunaux mixtes et
les commissions mixtes qui trancheront
c'est différent ce ne seront pas des
organes de l'union européenne et c'est
ce que voulait en effet la grande
bretagne mais c'est aussi acceptable par
l'union européenne le deuxième point
c'est la libre circulation des produits
des produits britanniques fabriqué en
grande bretagne sur le territoire de
l'union européenne et l'union européenne
évidemment veut vérifier que il n'ya pas
de dumping social
il n'y a pas de dumping environnemental
et que le gouvernement britannique où
les gouvernements des locaux te donne
pas des subventions indues à ces
produits là on est encore loin d'un
accord mais il est possible que
boris choisissent de sortir par le haut
en disant que bien entendu il n'est pas
question de réduire le niveau de
protection sociale en grande bretagne il
n'est pas question non plus de brader
des critères de respect de
l'environnement
les critères écologiques et e par
conséquent peu trop vous pourrez trouver
une formule d'assurance du mexique la
branche le respect de ces critères
merci à vendre la pêche effectivement le
problème reste très largement ouvert
mais il est possible de trouver un
compromis si on le veut et on verra on
sera ça cette semaine la bourse
aujourd'hui à monter un nombre comme à
paris et et on verra quels sont les les
mouvements l'aspect dans les prochains
jours merci à vous lance maison se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
nouveau journal un point complet sur
l'actualité instants avec nous
[Musique]
je
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui compte c'est
qu'on soit bien des lignes ont
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
musée l'intérêt ce soit contre le 11e
jeu
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview on parle de
l'afrique comme d'un continuant en
perpétuelle de vie son dysfonctionnement
actuel tient à l'absence de
redistribution à la population par des
dirigeants qui ont une fâcheuse tendance
à tout garder pour les pays occidentaux
ont favorisé cette dérive en
encourageant le maintien au pouvoir de
politiciens de plus en plus âgés pour
assurer la stabilité des pays et des
souris elles ont eu la prétention de
croire que les valeurs qu'elle défend
des est imposé par la force dans leur
conquête était universel dans cette
terre des possibles s'esquisse les
figures du monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture
et puis les espaces naturels c'est grâce
à la chasse grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
sont en grande partie conservée grâce à
la gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui
vous avez vingt trois ans vous êtes une
femme qu'est ce que vous espérez
apporter justement à ce monde de la
chasse si je peux aider avec avec ce que
je fais sur les réseaux sociaux etc